we mentioned the president is holding
five rallies today including some in
coronavirus hot spots and one target of
the crowd
scorn at last night's trump rally in
florida what doc was dr anthony fauci
the nation's top infectious disease
expert
so far president trump has not said what
could happen to dr
fauci if he wins a second term but that
may be changing
ed o'keefe is following both campaigns
ed good morning to you
what did the president say well good
morning tony the president appeared once
again to openly toy with the idea of
firing dr anthony fauci
because he's a career public servant the
president really could only demote
maybe sideline him but the criticism
comes as the doctor's given
yet another scathing interview where he
criticizes the administration's response
to the coronavirus wow what a crowd
at the president's rally last night the
crowd broke into chance calling for dr
anthony fauci's removal
[Applause]
don't tell anybody but let me wait till
a little bit after the election
the president can't technically fire the
career public servant
but fauci has yet again angered the
white house after he was asked by the
washington post
about the differences between the
campaigns fauci said the president's
looking at the virus from the
perspective of reopening the country
while the biden campaign is taking it
seriously from a public health
perspective
the white house called fauci's comments
unacceptable and accused him of being
partisan by praising the president's
opponent
the truth is to beat the virus we first
got to beat
donald trump
in philadelphia sunday biden slammed
president trump for his response to the
coronavirus which has disproportionately
affected communities of color
the former vice president is hoping
turnout here can help him carry
pennsylvania
a pivotal battleground state we need
every single one of you to get out
and to vote on tuesday my message is
simple
pennsylvania is critical to this
election but biden's road to the white
house is not without tension
no wonder there's so much traffic this
video shows trump supporters in texas
using trucks and cars to surround and
follow abiding campaign bus over the
weekend
it was traveling along interstate 35 and
no one was hurt
but in a tweet the president celebrated
the drivers writing
in my opinion these patriots did nothing
wrong and he was critical of the fbi's
decision
to investigate the incident people that
are driving down a highway with an
american flag and a trump flag right
don't worry they'll be just fine they're
going to be just fine
important to note that neither biden nor
harris nor their spouses were on that
bus
it was inviting campaign staffers and
volunteers and texas democratic
officials told me over the weekend
this was an isolated incident they're
aware of nothing else like it
happening at all in recent days in the
lone star state now today
the president as we mentioned is
visiting making five stops in four key
battleground states
joe biden begins the day in ohio a state
where his team sees some last minute
hope
of possibly turning it blue then he
spends the rest of today in western
pennsylvania
ending it at heinz field in pittsburgh
alongside lady gaga
and guys uh lest we forget because
there's been plenty of viewer inquiry
about this
uh there is just one day left until
election day
how many days one but just one
i want a zero board tomorrow ed in a
neighborhood full of big screens we
still go old school
there you go there better be a zero i
want to see a zero on the board tomorrow
all right okay thanks very much for you
tomorrow the o'keefe countdown calendar
goes on